were you incarcerated when it passed
what was that environment like
like how was that received in jail like
what was the the mood like in there
because man I I was on the radio the day
it was the Sunday he passed
and I could and I had a really good
relationship with nip you know
and I couldn't even tell you man I've
never experienced anything like being in
La it's Dev day to day
this is his birthday yeah so it's the
update today I just I've never
experienced like Kobe died and like and
listen man I shed a tear for Kobe too
but it was not like when Nick died that
[__] would probably [__] me up too but
when nip passed it you could like bro
I've never seen like a city heartbroken
like that the jail like I said I never
said [__] [__] that supposed to hate
the hood they crying the enemy's crying
everybody listened to him no matter if
they try to act hard like [__] nip at
the end of the day everybody [__] with
Nipsey yeah I mean like in his show like
the whole the south side is for sure you
know they love Nipsey yeah yeah yeah I
mean uh they was [__] up about it
everybody was [__] up like it was
crazy because I'm like
because uh op told me like hey bro
called in to see they say nip just got
killed through Kershaw sauce and I'm
like man stop playing with me he like he
like but this my boy though I'm like why
are you why is you playing with my own
boy he's like no I'm serious and uh he
like you could see like a tear trickling
down I'm like what the [__] I get to the
phone I'm like hey they like yeah I'm
like man what the [__] look like he's
like uh call right back we about to tell
you what happened we gonna tell you who
it was
I called back
and they tell me like they figure out
how to tell me when they tell me I'm
like
what the [__] is going on out there like
how the [__] did he where did he even
come from how did they get into it like
you know what I'm saying like that [__]
was crazy bro did you know uh Eric
Holder at all like did you have any sort
of like what you used to call you you
didn't always call me brick baby right
shitty [__] yeah so I remember I
remember having that conversation with
ill will like this guy's got to change
his name because he's never I can't say
his name on the radio you're the one
that made me change my name you don't
know that because it was you were [__]
was it [__] baby or shitty baby it was
break baby [__] truck that's what it was
yeah yeah yeah yeah I just remember
being like bro I can't say his name on
the radio I can't play his music but you
know my street name is shitty okay yeah
so so you knew Eric yeah I'm a little
shitty that's baby shitty so you're
doing pretty well yeah damn yeah yeah
that [__] is crazy yeah I I I I know him
knowing so when you found out it was
[__] me up it was like God damn like
what the [__] is going on like yeah I
mean
it's like
that [__] just was like what the [__]
like
it took me from crying to like no tears
because it's like
what the [__] is this like what the [__]
going on out there like you know I mean
I can't ask nobody everybody else here
been in jail yeah man I can't ask nobody
what's going on how what's the backstory
or nothing so I just know this and I
know that that shit's crazy man
do you think it was like
some [__] that because I feel like it it
came off like he was obviously
I don't know if it was like it just came
off like like some like some heartless
[__] or some [__] that like maybe like a
crackhead or a dope fiend type thing
would do like you hear so many different
things though yeah it was definitely of
like meth and all type of other like
yeah I mean whatever you know yeah
unless you living like that whatever
come across your plate so uh
he was he was definitely off drugs and
uh I don't know I wasn't there for the
conversation yeah I mean so I always
speculation I can't tell you what was
said what was not but obviously it was
something that said heavy on his brain
and and he doubled back and did whatever
he he did you have to say well he's
already accused I mean got found guilty
but he killed him
over pondering too much thinking too
much over something where it's like this
is a rumor in the hood if you know that
you didn't do it then leave I mean like
yeah you didn't do nothing right there
with the [__] did you double but now
your life's over yeah you just double
your life's overhead and you know that
your your boy who
this your brother me you know I [__]
with this dude on a day to day like this
my dude like you get what I'm saying
like you you you take yourself away from
everybody that you ain't thinking about
it like you could have double back and
[__]
like why would you throw your life away
on camera and and you got to be on drugs
you know what I'm saying like you know
you know you're not getting away with
this you out here with your shirt off
you doing all this [__] like you can't
be thinking the right way and tons of
people are standing there who aren't him
like you know it was just it was just it
to me it was like one of the more and
like I didn't you know it just feels
like I'm ready to go out type [__] yeah
like some suicide missions yeah that's
what it was like I'm ready to go out
[__] it that's the last thing I'm gonna
hear about some snitches like that I I
don't know I don't get it it's crazy
yeah I mean like recipes nift though
yeah he was a great guy man he was an
amazing guy
um